The Joe Rogan Experience so I take this
off and I it's a Whole Foods Market is
continuously my biggest customer
they used to be my virtually my only
customer
but my relationship with Whole Foods has
been cooling for a decade and eventually
I won't be in there anymore
uh I I will will Harris me sold Whole
Foods Market
the first pound of American grass-fed
beef that they marketed as American
grass-fed beef
20 years ago
and it all the time it was so lucky then
it just caught traction and and they
they wanted to buy all our souls
and and and but today it's a very
different Whole Foods uh and you know we
won't be there what's the issue
you know what green washing is green
washing yeah no sort of pre-washing is
big food
advertising
using words to
make consumers believe that
the food they're selling is the same as
what I'm producing
even though it's not
hey is that if you got that uh
a global animal partnership Whole Foods
video where you can show it to show
please
so green washing
green washing okay so what's this meat
rating system about let me put it this
way Step One is like
it's the five foot
so step five let's get a New York strip
and definitely a filet
what the hell does that mean I can't
tell you how much that anchors me tell
me what that means that makes me so good
is that there that's their question I
mean that is their video that they made
yeah that was their hours
come on it makes you laugh I'm sure it
does sir but as me as a as a consumer
looking at like what come on man the LA
you're supposed to be Whole Foods Whole
Foods to me is supposed to be a place
where I can go and get healthy food
that's like the the idea behind it Whole
Foods started by hippies started here in
Austin great Whole Foods I want Whole
Foods let me go there but what is and
this is what does that mean all right
you have so many things you could tell
me in a short period of time healthier
better for the environment you know low
carbon footprint it's all those things
they could tell me instead they go and
that's their commercial all right so
this this is about green washing okay
whole food and Hope foods and Global
animal partnership are are big on
greenwashing okay what is step five and
step four what is that so uh uh so let's
talk about the global animal partnership
okay the global animal partnership is an
animal welfare
non-profit that Whole Foods financed
I don't know 15 years ago or something I
don't know how long ago and I went to
the first
meeting producer meeting they overhead
in Denver of the Whole Foods had for the
global animal partnership rolling it out
and uh and it was all about this uh I
thought and by the way I thought it was
a great idea at the time
this uh Alamo welfare system so that
step one which is low hanging fruit a
little bit better than Industrial
two three four five and five was great
Animal Welfare uh no
physical alterations can't castrate
whatnot we used to castrate everything
born on my farm that wasn't named Harris
and we
and we quit castrating you know all the
things we had to do to achieve step five
and it was explained to us at the time
that uh you know we want to bring the
industry into higher Animal Welfare
which was right up my alley I did too
and we're going to have this step one
two which is low hanging fruit that
pretty much anybody it's like get your
foot in the door
but all companies are expected to move
up the continuum
to until everybody step four or five
okay I thought it was great sounds great
yeah
so I embraced it
and uh and became a step five plus I
don't think they have just a very few in
the country we want um
and they never would pay us any more for
our product it would you know just it
just but as a result
in the case the meat case everything was
step one step two maybe a little step
three
and they did allow producers mostly big
multinational corporations to come in at
step one student and languish there you
know 15 years later they still step one
step two which is not the way it was
supposed to work
so
now instead of even though there's five
steps they talk about how it's all great
and it's not already if you're going to
do it with your hands and mouth like
that guy you know so step one's like
step five is like
you're not
it just pisses me off I would imagine
but you go to Whole Foods you know and
look and ask them how much okay step
five how much step four and five you got
back there and probably not much
so most of it here goes Jimmy's got it
here step one no cages no crates no
crowding step two in gr enriched
environment things to do
step 3 enhanced outdoor access step 4
pasture centered based on an outdoor
system step five animal centered no
physical alterations that means
castration and then step five plus which
is you animal centered entire life on
the same Farm as Shoppers can know
exactly what the animal is raised for
the meat they are buying just by looking
for the same for the color-coded step
rating on the pro product label as of
October 1st 2014 step 5 program includes
two thousand five hundred two thousand
four hundred fifty one farms and ranches
that range from step one to step five
plus and raise more than 147 million
animals annually but they added
everything together there oh yeah step
five in program look how they did that
step five in program includes 2 451 Pro
farms and ranches that range from step
one to step five plus so by saying that
it includes these 2451 Farms they're not
saying how many of them are actually
step five they're like kind of [ __ ]
with you with the numbers there and I
can tell you it's not many it's not two
thousand four hundred fifty one but
that's step one two step five one I'm
not saying there weren't that many farms
not that many step five the distribution
would be greatly skewed right so if you
go to A Whole Foods and say hey
um so I want I want that how many you
got it's less far less so they have to
get very specific meat from places like
you well I mean I think the reason they
they had that particular segment valve
is because they didn't have much step
five back there so that that allowed
them to say hey man it's all good right
it's all good it's all better than
anywhere else you're gonna get yeah and
that's green washing that's green wash
that makes sense it devalues what the
step five plus does
yeah it's a kind of a it's a moronic way
of describing it it's a different Whole
Foods than the one I started with is it
because it's corporate now and it's
because it's owned by big companies and
it's all about when you're involved in a
gigantic corporation like that it's
about maximizing profits
everything you said is right the way I
would state it is that uh
industrialized farming and big food
distribution co-evolve together you know
prior to the end of World War II
there was no industrial farming
and there were really no great big food
companies retail companies you know
local Piggly Wiggly or whatnot but they
weren't
and those
those all Koval big AG big food and
Industrial farming co-evolved together
to what it is now
and you know the the guys that are
managing the meat Department's Whole
Foods
really need to pick up the phone and say
send me 48 000 pounds a truckload a 48
000 pounds of six ounce fillets to the
following five distribution centers
every week for the next month thank you
well the will harrises of The World
Won't oversee 48 000 pounds of six ounce
Ribeyes oh
families the only people that can do
that are
Tyson Cargill JBS Smithfield
so that's that co-evolution here
um
so the only way
this is going to work to do it your way
is if someone's deeply committed to
change yeah let me say this I also sell
to uh
a grocery chain called Market District
one called moms one called Publix one
called Kroger
and I don't feel as used as window
dressing
by those stores so you feel that like
your way of doing it is is almost like
it's a trick
they're trying to pretend that most of
their meat is gotten from people like
you that's that's my perception what you
just saw it seems like that was the
perception that I got from it too based
on the way they use that giant number
yeah and said it's anywhere from step
one to step five plus they kind of
lumped everybody in together you know
I'm so I'll actually sold Publix
supermarket
prior to selling Whole Foods I sold them
before I did Whole Foods and they public
stood I'm not it's not advertising they
have ordered consistently from me every
single week for 20 years
they put it out there
people
buy it or not
there's no [ __ ] there's no smoke and
mirrors and pursue you know it's just no
green washing no green washing it's just
just honestly bad or not
and you know again Whole Foods are still
my biggest customer I'm probably this
problem will get me thrown out if it
doesn't think so huh do you think they
will
I don't know you just don't seem to care
though
there ain't much of a nice kissing
business I like it
oh they uh they completely I mean you
know we'll have to work a little hard
and sell a little more
online you know but uh
but you'd prefer that
to [ __ ] yeah
you know uh there was a time that well
it's not good but this video yeah
it's it's just that's that's very
different company